قانون اسرائيلي جديد اقر بشكل مبدئي ينص
على سحب الجنسيه والمواطنه من اي فلسطيني
في القدس او الداخل اعتقل على خلفيه امنيه
وتلقى مساعده ماليه من السلطه الفلسطينيه
القانون يعتبر جزء من خطته وزير الامن
القومي ثمار والذي كان قد تعهد بتغيير نمط
الحياه الانسانيه والتنظيميه للاسرى
الفلسطينيين في السجون اذا اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار مثلا القدس التي دائما تحت
المركز الصداره في عدد المعتقلين يعني
عمليه تهويد واخلاق تفريخ عمليه تهجير
جماعي وزير الامن القومي من جديد كان قد
زار سجن نافحه واطلق بعدها سلسله تصريحات
بدات تترجم على ارض الواقع من ابرزها
تنقلات واسعه في الاقسام بناء اقسام جديده
في السجون اصغر حجما لمنع التجمعات
التنظيميه تهديدات بمنع فتره الاستراحه
الجماعيه ومنع الاهالي من ادخال المساعدات
الماليه لذويهم وسحب الكثير من الامتيازات
التي حققها الاسرى في السجون سابقا
اجراءات من شانها ان تفجر مواجهه كبرى
خارج اسوار السجون تهدد بها حركه فتح في
الضفه وحماس في غزه سنكون
في اي معركه شعبنا الفلسطيني لافتاء
المخططات من غفير وحكومه اليمين المتطرفه
لن تكون كسابقاتها والعروس يتحمل نتائج اي
معركه القادمه ويقطعوا في السجون
الاسرائيليه نحو اربعه الاف 5400 اسير
منهم 600 اسير مريض ونحو 20 اسيرا معتقلين
منذ نحو 30 عاما وتعتبر قضيه الاسرى من
القضايا القليله الباقيه التي تتمتع
باجماع وطني يتجاوز الانقسام وخلافات
الفصائل نقل الاسرى ان اداره السجون
ابلغتهم انها قد لا توافق على بعض
الاجراءات لكنها مضطره لتنفيذها بقرار من
الوزير
فرد الاسرى انه حال تنفيذ هذه الاجراءات
سيلجاون الى العصيان والتمرد قبل استعمال
السلاح الاخير المتمثل بالاضراب العام عن
الطعام من قباله سجن عوفر الاسرائيلي عبد
الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه